there was a video just went viral on
tick tock of a preschool preschool
teacher
talking about how she is indoctrinating
her kids in transgender ideology
says to the parents who refuse to
educate their kids on queerness i'm an
openly non-binary trans preschool
teacher
i talk to my students about pronouns
transness gender expression and
sexuality
hahaha right you you parents think
you're going to keep this away from your
kids well no because i'm going to teach
them about it
now
i i give the
woman or man or non-binary or i don't
know i'm not going to venture a guess
here
i give this individual
some credit at least for
the courage of his or her convictions
a lot of conservatives won't won't say
what they need to say which is
we need to ban these ideas from the
classroom right that's what the parents
in loudoun county and elsewhere are
saying they're saying we don't want you
can't shouldn't teach our kids a bunch
of false nonsense about their sex or
their race or whatever
and a lot of the conservative elites
will say well no we don't we don't
support banning any ideas from the
classroom why not if you don't support
banning ideas from the classroom then
how do you stop that how do you stop
this lunatic pervert individual from
indoctrinating your three-year-old into
believing that little johnny is little
jane how do you do it
if you're not willing to stand by the
courage of your convictions how do you
stop it
speaking of
tick tock lunatics there's another
i go through these tick tock videos not
only because they're amusing
they are amusing often but because
they're extremely educational and
extremely insightful like this
guy who is dressed up like a woman
who says you might oppose transgenderism
but you will respect transgenderism
let me tell you something about lgbtq
right it's about
trends rights this is only going in one
direction
you will respect us
you can be upset
you can be angry you can think it's
unfair you can feel like we're stealing
something from you
but it's still only going in one
direction
you will
respect
us he's right
he's right you will you will respect
transgenderism
you will because if you don't
you'll be punished
so you and you might not believe it in
your heart of hearts and you might still
think it's crazy but you will show
public respect for it
because the boot of the establishment
will come down on your neck if you don't
he's absolutely right
the the lie the delusion was
that these radical ideologies merely
seek
acceptance
just be tolerant
just be inclusive just be accepting
no it was never about that
they seek
affirmation
they demand affirmation they have to
why because we live in a society because
we're not just atoms floating in the
ether and so
you cannot have a society
in which the country is split
radically split on the question of what
is human nature
we have to agree on some things if we're
going to have a society and at the very
least you need to agree on what a human
being is
and if half the country
i don't think it's quite this much but
let's let's say it's the left believes
one thing the right believes the other
half the country believes that
human nature has nothing to do with your
body
and the other half believes that it does
and you know one half believes that men
can become women and do and the other
half believes that they can't you're not
going to be able to function you're not
going to be able to speak to one another
you're not going to know what pronouns
to use we currently don't know what
pronouns to use and so you're going to
have to resolve that question
at the public level
so what's it going to be
and what the liberals will tell you is
look you might have your personal
reservations about transgenderism but we
all need to agree on accepting it at the
political level
you might have your personal
reservations about abortion but we all
need to agree that we should kill 60
million babies since roe vs wade
and it's just it's just a trick
it's just a little political slate of
hand that has given them the entire
culture the live and let live language
of the left
was never real it was never serious it
was always an instrument toward
achieving their ends
academic freedom the free marketplace of
ideas live and let live it was always a
lie
okay and now the right is befuddled and
they'll say what happened to the
tolerance so much for the tolerant left
what happened to live and let live what
happened to they never meant it that's
what happened it was always a lie to
trick you into giving up your culture
and your standards
and now they've got the upper hand and
they are doing what they naturally would
do which is enforce their own standards
like all societies
so what's what's the alternative
the new york times tells us what the
alternative is the new york times new
york times it's just like these wackos
on tick tock sometimes the new york
times will unwittingly give you the
right answer to political problems
guest essay
headline is what happened to poland
warsaw
not long ago poland was seen as the most
successful example of democratic
transformation in central and eastern
europe a leader in european integration
it was enjoying as the long-time
european commissioner gunter verhugen
wrote a new golden age today the country
is again ahead of others only this time
it's in the vanguard of european
disintegration and democratic
dismantling
poland possesses a traumatic nervous
sense of itself the current government
has tried to channel that anxiety
invading against migrants brussels and
liberals to create a fortress mentality
despite occasional setbacks such as the
president's decision to veto a
controversial media bill
it has succeeded
so what are they actually they're saying
that
poland was really democratic
when it was doing exactly what the
people in brussels the leaders of the
european union the people who were not
accountable to the citizens of poland
wanted them to do
so when poland was suppressing the will
of its own people and just going along
with what a distant tyrant told them to
do that was democratic but now that
poland is doing what its own people want
them to do and doing what its own people
elected them to do now its
anti-democratic do you see the problem
there
do you see
as i have said for quite a while i
actually wrote a book on this topic
called speechless controlling words
controlling minds the left has just
redefined democracy to mean not
democracy
they've completely switched the meaning
of democracy
how does this make any sense how do they
get away with it adrian vermeul the
harvard law professor
one of the greatest twitter accounts has
a great sub stack also with some other
good good thinkers called the
post-liberal order adrian vermeel points
out that
if you just switch out the words
democracy and liberalism
things start to make sense
what the left considers democracy
is
not when you follow the will of the
people but when you just go along with
some elite liberal idea this is why when
the people elect donald trump that's a
threat to democracy and it's why
when
the people's will is thwarted that is a
vindication of democracy if it goes in
the left-wing
direction
so what are we going to have which way
are we going to what poland has done is
become much more conservative and said
no to the distant liberal elites in
brussels and has said yes to its own
culture and its own history and its own
religion it's become significantly more
christian don't forget poland played a
big role in the fall of the soviet
empire
poland when the polls came out when
saint john paul ii walked up and they
chanted we want god we want god
they which way are we going to go are we
going to go in the direction of elite
liberal rule
or are we going to channel the
legitimate frustrations of the people
who no longer have confidence in their
own ruling class which seems
increasingly to despise them and
consider them deplorable and
irredeemable which side are we going to
take liz cheney's right that we need to
make a choice she's wrong about what
that choice is and she's on the wrong
side of it but we will need to make that
choice hold up did you like that clip
don't be honest don't just flatter me
i hope you did if you did ring that bell
subscribe you'll get the notifications
if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there maybe leave a five-star
review i don't know
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]